In this lesson, we will talk about one of the
most famous and fundamental algorithms in computer
science binary search, we find the application of
binary search in a large number of problems in a
large variety of problems in computer science. But
here, let's try to learn it in its simplest form.
And to do so, we will define a problem first,
the problem is given a sorted array of integers,
a sorted array means that the elements in the
array are arranged either in increasing order
or in decreasing order like in this array, here
the elements are arranged in increasing order,
let's say the name of this array is a the size
of this array is nine. So we have index starting
zero till eight. Now given such an
array and a number or an integer x,
we want to find out whether x exists in this
array or not. And if x exists in this array,
then we want to find out the position at
which x exists in this array. So for example,
if x is at one does it even exist in the
array? Yes, it even exists in the array and
it exists at index seven, does 25 exists in
the array no 25 does not exist in the array
does 21 exist in the array? Yes, 21 exists in
the array at position three at index three.
Now, what would be the logic to find out whether x
exists in this array or not? One simplest approach
can be that we can scan the whole array to find
out the desired number. So we start at index zero,
and compare this element with x. If it is equal
to x, then we are done with our search we are we
have found the element in the array. If not, we
go to the next element. And we keep on comparing
with the next element until either we are finished
with the array, or we find the number. So let's
say if we wanted to find 63 in this array, then
our search will be over when we teach index six,
we start at index zero and our search will be over
at index six. If we wanted to find a 25 our search
will be over at index eight with the
conclusion that 25 does not exist in the array.
This approach will work irrespective
of whether the array is sorted or not.
And if I have to write the code for this,
it will be pretty straightforward. Let's say
I want to write a method search that takes an
array A its size N and the element sorry number
x to be searched for and the code would be we
will run a loop starting zero till n minus one.
So for I starting zero to n minus one,
if the element at index i is equal to x,
then we return I which means returning the
position at which we have found element x and
our search will be over. And if we cannot find
any such AI then we return minus one, let's say
returning minus one means that we could not find
the element we could not find x in the array.
Now with this algorithm, if we are lucky, we
will find x at first position itself. So in
the best case, we will make only one comparison
and we will we will be able to find the result
in the worst case when x would not even be
present in the array we will scan the whole
array we will make n comparisons with all the
elements in the array and then we will be able to
give back a result that hey x does not exist
in the array. So the time taken in the worst
case is definitely proportional to the input
size of the array, sorry, size of the array.
Or in other words, we say that this would
be big O of n in terms of time complexity,
it's always good to analyze the running time
of an algorithm in the worst case and find out
the upper bound of the time taken. Now, in this
case, the time taken grows as a linear function of
n. So, we also call this search linear search. And
once again, if we are using linear search, we are
not using any property like the array sorted or
not whether that is sorted or not this will work.
Now, let us try to improve this algorithm
using the extra property of the array
that it is sorted and I will make some space here
first. Let us say we want to find out whether 13
number 13 exists in the array. So x is 13. And we
want to find out whether x exists in the array.
Now we will use a different approach this time
instead of instead of comparing x with the first
element, as we do in the case of linear search,
we will compare it with the middle element in
the array. Now the size of this array is nine so
the middle element will be at index four Now there
can be three cases here. case one can be that x is
equal to the middle element. If x is equal to the
middle element, we have already found
x in the array. case two can be when x
is less than the middle element, and case three
can be that x is greater than the middle element.
Clearly, if x is equal to the
middle element our search is over.
Because we have found x in the array, if x
is less than the middle element, then because
the array is sorted, it lies before the middle
element. And we can discard the middle elements,
middle element and all the elements after middle
element. Similarly, if x is greater than the
middle element, it lies after the middle elements.
So we can discard all the elements before the
middle element, and of course, the middle
element as well. So in case two, and three,
we discard half the elements from our search space
and reduce our search space. So in this example,
when x is 13, initially, our search space is the
whole array, X can exist anywhere in the array.
Now we compare it with the middle element, which
is 36. Now x is less than 36. So it exists,
it should exist somewhere before 36. So we
discard all the elements after 36 and 36, as well.
So now the problem gets redefined, we need
to search x only between index zero to
three. So how do we keep track of the search
space, we keep track of the search space using
two indices start and end. So initially,
the start would be zero, and n would be
the last element in the array, in this case,
the index eight because initially the whole
array is our search space. And we calculate
made as start plus n upon too. Now once we
find out our reduced search space, we adjust
Start and End accordingly. So in this case,
after comparing 13 with 36, and discarding half
of the array, our end now becomes index three,
which is nothing but one less than the middle
element. Now we again find out the middle
element in this reduced search space. So here the
middle element will be three plus zero by two,
if we take only the integral part three plus
zero by two would be 1.5. And if we take the
integral part the middle element will be
index one once again is it equal to x?
No six is not equal to 13 is x less than the
middle element? Is it case two? No, it is not x
is greater than the middle element. So this time,
we discard the middle element and all the elements
towards its left and this time we shift start to
mark our new search space. Now, the new search
space is starting at index two and ending at index
three. Now, what is the middle element three plus
two is five five by two is 2.5 and the integral
part is two. So this is our middle element.
So x is not equal to middle element we have found
our element. So we are done with our search.
This kind of search where we reduce the search
space into half at each comparison is called
binary search. Once again we are able to reduce
the search space by two or in other words,
we are able to reduce the search space into
half only because the array is sorted array
being sorted is a precondition for binary search.
Okay, so let us now write code for this algorithm.
I will write a method binary search
that we'll take as argument and array A,
its size N and a number x to be searched for in
the array and I will initialize two variables
start to zero and end to n minus one. So start
and end define our search space initially the
whole area is the search space. Now,
I will write a condition here while
start is less than or equal to and I'll come
back to why I am writing this condition. So
while this is true start is less than or
equal to and we will find out the middle
index of the search space as start plus end upon
two. And now we will write three cases. If the
middle element is equal to x, then our search is
over. We return the index stored in the variable
made and exit from the function. If x is less than
the middle element, then we need to discard all
the elements having index greater than or equal
made. So our end of the search space now becomes
mid minus one. And in the third condition,
which will be x greater than the middle element,
which will be the default condition after these
two if and else if we need to discard all the
elements with index less than or equal to
mid, so, our start becomes mid plus one.
And if we exit this while loop
without returning anything,
then we return minus one, which will mean that we
were not able to find the element x in the array.
Now, why this wild statement here with a
condition start less than or equal to end,
what we are basically doing in our algorithm is
that we are reducing our search space recursively
by adjusting the start and the end pointer. Now,
there must be an exit condition to our recursion,
the exit condition can be either we find the
element in the array, so, we return and exit
or we exhaust the whole search space when start
is equal to end or start is less than E and then
we still have such space, when start is equal to n
then our space has only one element. So, when this
condition becomes false, we have exhausted
our search space, we need to exit the loop
and we need to return minus one to tell that the
element the number x does not exist in the array.
Now, once again in this case in the best case,
we can find the element x in just one comparison,
when the first middle element itself will be the
element x in the worst case, we will keep reducing
the search space till the search space becomes
one element. So, from n we reduce to n by to
and from n by two we reduce to n by four and we
go on till our search space becomes one. Now, how
many steps does it take? Let's do some math here.
Let's say it takes k steps to reduce n to one
by keep by dividing by two at each step.
So, n by two upon K will be equal to one
and if you solve this, then k will be equal to log
of n the base will be two. So, in the worst case,
binary search will take log n comparisons and
so, the time taken also in the worst case is
proportional to log in or in other words, it
is big O of log n in terms of time complexity
and big O of log n is a lot lot lot more efficient
than o n algorithm. So this was binary search,
we will take more problems on binary search
in the coming lessons. Thanks for watching.
In the previous lesson, we learned about binary
search as an efficient algorithm to find or search
element in a sorted data in a sorted collection.
In this lesson, in some real code, we will see how
to implement binary search. And we will also
see what are the common errors that happen
while implementing binary search. But before that,
a quick recap, let's say we have a sorted array of
integers something like this, the elements are
arranged in increasing order and the size of
the array is six. So the indices are from zero
to five. Now, let us say we want to find out
whether the number 10 exists in this array or
not programmatically using binary search. Now,
in binary search, what we do is we take two
pointers to variables that point to that initially
point to the first and the last element in the
array, we may call them start and end pointers,
we may call this variable start and end or we
may also call this low and high to mark the lower
index and the higher index. Now start and end
these two variables at any stage in our algorithm
give us the range in which the element can
the element may exist. So this at the start
of the algorithm, the element may exist anywhere
within the array. So that's why Start and End are
pointing to the first and the last element. Now we
calculate middle point using the equation middle
is equal to low plus high upon two or start plus
end upon two and we take only the integral part.
So here five plus 0.2 would be 2.5. And taking
the integral part will give us this index two
as the middle index. So we are searching for 10
number 10. And initially we are in a state where
lower index is zero, higher index is five and so
mid index is two. Now we see that the element at
the middle index is the desired element. If it
is the desired element our search is over. So
the element at the middle index is six is six
equal to 10. No it is not. Now we see whether
this element is greater than The target element
or less than the target element, now six is less
than the target element which is 10. So we
discard six and all the elements before six,
because they are also less than 10. And we
shift start to point at index three. So we go to
this state lower index three higher index five
and now we search for our number in this part
of the array only. Now if we calculate mid and
mid is equal to four five plus three upon two,
is it equal to the target element 10? Yes, it is
equal to so we have found found our element on our
search is over, we found 10 at index four. Okay,
what if we were we were searching for the number
nine in the array, if we were searching for nine
till this tape, it would have been the same thing.
Now at this step, the middle element is 10 we
compare it with nine and I'll also modify it
here now 10 is greater than nine. So definitely
nine can only exist before 10 we need to discard
this part of the array and we need to go to
a state where our search space is defined
by low equal three and high equal to three now
three is both low and high and mid element of
this range would also be three only. Now, this
middle element is also not equal to our desired
number nine is not equal to eight. Now, once we
have only one element in our search space and
we have still not found our desired element our
search is over and we could not find the element.
Let us now implement binary search
and I will write a C program now.
Okay. So, what I will do here
is I will first write a method
named binary search that will take an integer
array its size, let's say the size of the array is
n and let's say the element to be searched for
is x and this method returns an integer which
will be the L index of x if it is found in the
array. Now, we will declare two variables low
and high and initialize them to zero and n minus
one respectively low and high at at any point
give us the segment within which x may lie okay.
So, now we declare another variable made that
is calculated as low plus high upon two. Now, we
compare x to the element at index made and there
can be three conditions here first condition
will be when x is equal to the middle element
the element at index made and in this case our
search is over we will simply return the index
made and when we return from our method we exit
it now the second case can be when x is less than
a made now, because x is less than the
middle element it will lie before made.
So, now we redefine our segment by shifting end
to shifting the higher index to mid minus one
and the should be as f okay and the third and
the last condition which will be the default
condition here when x will be greater
than the middle element in this case,
we will redefine the segment by adjusting the
start are the lower index and lower index will
be equal to mid plus one. Now, we need to keep
repeating these three steps again and again.
So, how do we do that, so, we will definitely need
a loop. So we will put a while loop here. Now,
when do we stop executing these steps we
stop either when we find elements. So,
either when we return or when we are done
looking at all the elements. So I will put
a condition here while low is less than or equal
to high, when low becomes greater than high then
the segment defined by low and high will not
be a valid segment, Melo is equal to hi then
we will have only one element in the segment.
Now if we exit this while loop without returning
anything, then we can say that the element x is
not in the array let's say we return minus one to
say that x does not exist in the array okay. So
this is the binary search method. And and let
us now write the main method and try to use this
function. In the main method, I will first declare
and initialize an array let's say the name of the
array is a and we fill some elements into this
array in sorted order. Remember, the array being
sorted is a precondition for binary search. Okay,
so this is an array of size eight. Now let's ask
the user to enter a number that we will search in
array. So we will write a printf statement here
and now let us in a take input of this number.
Now I will call binary search to search
whether this Number exists in the array or not
size of the res eight and we want to find out
x Okay I will rather name this as x, because
we have been naming the target element
as x throughout okay. So, now if
index which is the return from the method binary
search is not equal to minus one then we have
found the element x in a. So, at this stage we
will print something like number x is at index
index index is the variable name as well else we
will print that we could not find x in the array.
Let us now run this program and see what happens.
So, we are asked to enter a number let's say
we want to search for number 15 in the array
okay. So, this says that number 15 is at index
six and let us now try to search a number that
does not exist in the array let's say we want to
search for 18 and output is number 18 not found
there are some common errors that happen in
binary search implementation resetting these
indexes low and high should be done correctly
and we should always be careful about this
exit condition from the loop. One more common
error is when people do not put this bracket here
now, what will happen here is that the
precedence of division operator is more
so, high by two will be calculated first and
then it will be added to low so, this bracket
is important we need to put this bracket here
and some people also calculate mid as instead
of calculating it as low plus high upon two we
also calculated sometimes as low plus high minus
low upon two and this is a better way of doing
it because sometimes low plus high can exceed
the maximum value that an integer can store. So,
like a 32 bit integer or 32 bit signed integer
can store maximum value of two to the power
31. Now, if both low and high are pretty high,
then high plus low will exceed two to the power
31 and cause issues in our program execution
it should be pretty evident that this expression
evaluates to high plus low upon two only. The only
difference is that we are avoiding overflow by
not calculating high plus low in this expression.
Okay. So, this was binary search implementation.
And in this implementation we have used loop so we
have written a an iterative implementation, you
can write binary search using recursion also,
I would recommend that you try that on your
own. In the coming lessons, we will see more
variations of binary search and its application
in other scenarios. So thanks for watching.
In our previous lesson, we learned about binary
search and we also implemented binary search,
but we implemented an iterative version of binary
search in which we used loop to write our program.
Now in this lesson, we will write binary
search using recursion. Let us first quickly
write an iterative version of binary search. So,
I will write a method binary search that will take
as argument a sorted array the size of the array
n and an element x that is to be searched for,
then we initialize two variables low and
high low to zero and high to n minus one.
And we say that while low is less than or
equal to high, calculate middle index as
low plus high upon two. It's a better practice to
calculate mid as low plus high minus low upon two,
which is the same thing except that we are not
calculating low plus high sometimes low and high
individually are within the limit of within the
range of an integer variable but high plus low
overflows the range or limit of an integer
variable. Now there are three conditions if
x is equal to the middle element we have found x
in the array so our search is over we return the
index made and exit else if x is less than the
mid element, we are just high to mid minus one
two to say that we discard anything which
is on or after made, because x is less than
the middle element and that is sorted as if x is
greater than a made which should be implicit here.
For the third condition. As the third condition
in this case we said low as made plus one.
And if we come out of this while
loop without finding anything,
we will return minus one to say that x does not
exist. In the array, what we are essentially doing
here is that if we have an array in which elements
are in increasing order, then we first compare
x with the middle element. And if x is equal to
the middle element, it's fine. If x is less than
the middle element, it must exist before
this element in this highlighted section,
and if x is greater, it must exist after
the middle element in this particular
highlighted section. And we keep on retied
repeating this process in the new segment.
until either we find x or we cannot divide the
search space any further at low equal high our
search space becomes or rather reduces to size one
reduces to only one element. After that we cannot
divide it any further. Binary search is a typical
example of a divide and conquer algorithm in which
at each step we are dividing the problem into
half. Let us now write recursive implementation.
So once again, I will write a method binary search
that will take a sorted array A and this time the
arguments will change a little we will take two
arguments low and high to mark the segment of
the array in which x may lie at any stage x is the
element to be searched for. And the logic would be
something like once again, we will calculate the
mid index. And then we will have three conditions.
If we find x, that's good, we return the index at
which we have found it. If x is less than a made,
we call binary search recursively on the range
low. And I'm running short of space here. So
I'll create some space here. And we will run
the we will call binary search recursively for
index low to mid minus one. So x is now to be
searched between index low to mid minus one
else if x is greater than a mid, which
will be the third condition anyway,
we will return binary search from mid plus
one to high so we make a recursive call to
search eggs from index made plus one
tail Hi, when we write recursion,
we should always look for a base case a base
condition where we would stop our recursion
in this case, we will stop our recursion if we
find the element. So, this case will return an
exit and we will not make any further recursive
call, but what if we do not find the element
what what if we do not find x in the array we
have another base condition for that where we
need to exit if low is greater than high then we
do not have a valid segment in the array. And in
this case, we can say that we have exhausted our
search space. So we return minus one to say that
x does not exist in the am short of space here. So
I'm writing these two statements in the same line.
So, these two are our base conditions that
would cause the recursion to stop or exit
and this condition low greater than highs the
same condition which we are checking here to
stop the loop. Let us now quickly simulate this
recursion using an example. Let's say we have
this array A a sorted array of size nine and
we want to search for number 63 in this array.
So we make a call to the function binary search
and I will write b s here a shortcut for binary
search okay we pass to the function the array and
lower index should be zero and higher index should
be able to say that initially the number can exist
anywhere in the array from index zero to eight
and the number to be searched for is 63 now we
go inside the function is low greater than high
No. So we go ahead and calculate mid mid would
be calculated as for the element at index made
index four is 36 and 63 is greater than 36. So,
we come to this else condition the third condition
and we make a recursive call to search for 63
within range mid plus one would be five to eight.
Now once again for this function low greater than
high is not true. So we calculate mid mid would be
six if we take only the integral part and element
at index six is 63. So we have found this element
we will return made so we return six here and this
method finishes and this method also returns six
to its color maybe the main method. Let us
now say that we want to search for number 25
so we make this call to binary search from the
main method. Now once again we calculate the
made now element at index 436 is greater than 25.
So we make a recursive call to search for 25 from
index zero to three. Okay now is low
greater than high is zero greater than
three no so we go ahead and calculate made
Made would be one element at index one is 625
is greater than six. So we make a recursive call
to search for 25 between indices two and three,
now made would be two, and this time, we will
make a recursive call to find 25 in the range
three to three, it's still a valid range low
is not greater than high, mid would be three.
And now 25 is greater than 21. So we make a
recursive call using the third condition to
mid plus one would be four and lower high would
be three still, and this time low is greater than
high. So we come to this condition, where this
method simply returns minus one and finishes.
Now this method also returns minus one
and this gets propagated all the way up.
And finally, this method returns minus one to its
color the main method while writing recursion,
we must be very careful about the base conditions,
like we have these two base conditions here.
If we do not get our base conditions, right,
our recursion may go on endlessly causing the
program's memory to overflow and causing it to
crash. The time complexity of this algorithm
is big O of log n, the time taken is proportional
to login. And this comes from the fact that if we
keep dividing the size of the array by two at each
step, then it will take us log n steps to reach
array size equal to one. Now one obvious question
which one is better the recursive implementation
or recursive implementation or an iterative
implementation? Well, anything that we can write
using recursion, we can write it using iteration
and anything we can write using iteration, we can
write it using recursion, iteration is a slightly
more performant. It's better in performance,
because we do not have to store all these states
of all these functions, the extra functions in
the memory. But writing recursion may sometimes
be very intuitive and easy to write. For most
practical reasons, you may choose any of these
according to your comfort. So that's not an issue.
Okay, so this was recursive implementation of
binary search for you. Thanks for watching.
In the previous lesson, we saw the implementation
of binary search in its basic form, we solved a
problem in which if we have a sorted array of
integers, something like this, and if we want
to find out whether a number exists in this array
or not. So let's say we want to find out whether
number 10 exists in this array or not, then our
algorithm returns us that 10 exists at index
three. And if we want to search for a number that
does not exist in the array, then our algorithm
returns us that the number that we're looking
for does not exist in an array. So if we want
to search for 11 in this array, then our algorithm
says that 11 does not exist in the array. Okay, so
now, I will modify this array. Now, this array is
still sorted, but the only difference is that we
have three occurrences of number 10 in the array.
Now, let's say we want to search for the number 10
using binary search, then what will be the index
of 10 that will return we could return to also
index to also we could return index three also. Or
we could return index four also, the normal binary
search implementation that we saw previously
exits as soon as it finds out any occurrence of
a number in the array, so there is no guarantee
that we will find the first occurrence or the
last occurrence. Now in this lesson, we will see
two different variations of binary search, one
variation will always give us the first occurrence
of a number in the array. And another variation
will always give us the last occurrence of the
number that we are searching for in the array.
Okay, so let us first write the basic
implementation that we had written previously.
I'll quickly write a method binary search
that takes three arguments array, its size N,
and the element to be searched for x. And we
will initialize two variables low and high
to zero and n minus one to mark the segment of the
array in which x is probable to lie. And while low
is less than or equal to high, we calculate
the middle index as low plus high upon two,
and then we compare x with the middle element.
And if x is equal to the middle element,
then we have found exe and our search is over. We
exit from the method by returning this index made.
So we are exiting as soon as we found as soon
as we find any occurrence occurrence of x, not
necessarily the first or the last occurrence, but
any occurrence. If x is less than the mid element,
we add just high to mid minus one to say that
x will now x is now probable to lie before the
mid element and the third and default condition.
When x is greater than the mid element, so, in
this case we had just low to mid plus one. And if
we come out of this while loop without finding x,
then we return minus one to say that we could not
find x in the array. Okay, let us see a simulation
of this for this particular example simulation
of this algorithm for this particular example,
I will draw three columns here, low, high and mid.
And let's say the number to be searched for is
10. So x is 10, size of the array
six, So, initially low is zero,
so the size of the array is seven. So, initially
low is zero high is six. Now, we have started to
execute this while loop we calculate made as low
plus high upon two, so mid would be three. Let's
also drag column A made, okay, this looks better.
Now, a three is 10. So is x equal to A made?
Yes, it is. So we return three, we return three.
And we will say that game over because we have
found an injury and we return immediately we do
not care that there is another 10 at index two.
Now, if we want to find out, if we wanted to
find out the first occurrence of 10 in the array,
we should not have said gameover we should have
said that Okay, I have found 110 at index three,
let me go and see towards the left, if there is
another 10 at any lower index. And if it is there,
I will return that one. So I will modify this
algorithm slightly here. At the beginning,
let's say we take a variable result, and
initialize it to minus one. I'll come back to why
I'm initializing it to minus one. And I'm short of
space here. So I'm writing two statements in the
same line with a comma. Now, when the condition
is that x is equal to the middle element,
instead of returning and exiting the execution
of the function, we modify result to x.
Sorry, we modify result to made the index at
which x lies and we adjust high to mid minus one.
Once again, I'm short of space here, so I'm
writing two statements in the same line. So,
these two statements will execute for this
condition if x is equal to the middle element.
Now, what do I really mean here, what I mean is
that if we found x in the array, then we have
stored the index in the variable result at which
we found x and then we modify our segment we do
not stop our search and we modify our search
space by adjusting high to mid minus one. So,
we keep on searching for x before this mid
element. So, if we see the simulation now,
then we do not stop here we make highest two
and continue our search now mid would be one
a mid would be for I will also write the value
of result at any state. So far our result is
so far we have found 10 at index three. So, our
result is three now for this case low zero high
two and mid one we will go to the condition this
one when x is greater than the middle element,
so low becomes mid plus one so low becomes
too high is already too now made would also
be to a mid would be 10 Now we come to this
condition, we again came to x equal to the
middle element of the segment. So we now modify
result to the new index at which will have found
x so results will be now two and high becomes mid
minus one which will be one low is two now this
condition lower less than or equal to high fails.
So we exit y loop here okay there should be one
more modification to my code, I will return result
here okay. So, we are seeing here that found 10
at index two. So, this way, we have found the
first occurrence of the element 10 in the array
we are returning result here once we complete the
while loop and we are not returning result inside
the loop, the result is initially minus one. So
if we do not find any x it is never modified. And
we return minus one to say that we could not find
x in the array. And if we find any x in the array
and I'll quote put braces here to mark that these
two statements execute for this if condition,
we stored that index in this variable
kind of saying that so far, this is the
leftmost result that I have. And then we go
on searching towards the left by left a means
towards the lower indexes. So we modify high to
mid minus one if we find another x, then this x
is left of the previous index. So we discard the
previous result and modify our result okay. So,
this is binary search to find out the occurrence
of first element in the array. If we want to find
out the last occurrence in the array, then there
will be only a slight modification to this code.
When we find x we do not stop the search like we
are doing here. And we go on searching towards the
right towards the higher indices by modifying our
window window or the segment or the search space
by adjusting lower to mid plus one by adjusting
lower index to mid plus one And this is the
only change that we need to do to find out last
occurrence in the array okay. So, let us quickly
see simulation for this implementation also.
So, once again we start with low zero high six
and we also start with the result minus one minus
one means that we have not found x in the array
so far now made would be three and the mid element
would be 10 we are executing the while loop here,
now, we come to this condition x is equal to a mid
So, first we modify our result we found an x at
index three and then we modify low to mid plus one
which would be four. So, earlier our window was
the whole array. Now, our vendor spaces this and
we already have information about the right most
10 that has occurred so far Okay, so, now mid
would be five a mid would be 18 now, we go to
this condition x is less than a made so, now
high becomes mid minus one So, we have this range
our window or search space is now this and
so far we have found 110 at index three
now mid would be five plus four upon two and
if we take only integral part then it is for
a mid would be 10. So, once again we come to the
come to the condition when x is equal to image so
we modify the result to the new index four and we
modify lower to mid plus one So, low becomes five
high becomes five. So, far the highest
index of 10 that we have found is four and
our search window is now only index five. So,
mid would also be five and a mid would be 18.
Now 80 is greater than 10. So, we will again
once again go to this particular condition.
So low is still five and high becomes four
now. Now this is not a valid search space,
this is not a valid segment low less than or equal
to high condition fails, so we will exit the loop,
exit the while loop and our game is over we
deserve we return whatever we have in the result.
So we will kind of say that found 10 at index
four. So this is binary search to find out the
last occurrence of an element in the array
in a sorted array. The time complexity of
this algorithm is big O of log n. Or in other
words, we can say that the time taken is kind of
proportional to log of n. In the coming lessons,
we will see more variations of binary search,
we will see other scenarios in which binary
search is applied. So thanks for watching.
In this lesson, we will solve a very
famous programming interview question.
And the question is that, given a sorted
list of integers, we want to find out
how many times a particular
element occurs in this list.
So let's say we are given a list in the form
of an array. Here we have an array of size 12.
And the elements are in increasing order. Now how
many times does number five occur in this array,
five occurs five times and how many times
does number two occur in this array,
two does not occur in the array. So we will be
given any such sorted array and a number x. And
we have to find out how many times this number x
exists in this array. Now we want to solve this
problem programmatically. So let us think through
the different approaches that we may want to
follow. The simplest approach is that we can scan
the whole array and count the occurrences of x
in the array. So if I have to write a function
find count that will take as arguments array, its
size N, and the element x to be searched for the
element x for which we want to find out the count.
So the logic would be pretty straightforward,
we will take a variable initially,
let's say the name of the variable is count and
we initialize it to zero. And then we run a loop
starting zero till n minus one. And if a I or the
element at index i is equal to the element x, we
increment count. So count becomes count plus one
and finally when we count come out of this loop,
we return count. So we are performing a
linear search where we are scanning the whole
array to search for element x. We could optimize
this algorithm a little bit, something like this,
because the array is sorted once we reach a
stage, when AI becomes greater than x, we can stop
counting. But still in the worst case, this loop
will run n times. When all the elements in the
array are same then This loop will run n times.
So in the worst case, this algorithm, the running
time of this algorithm is proportional to n. In
other words, the time complexity is big O of n.
This is a very simple solution for this problem.
And if you give this solution in a programming
interview, the interviewer would be like, I
do not like this, give me something better.
So, how do we find out a better solution?
Whenever in a problem, we are given a sorted
data or a sorted collection, we should try to
think about applying one very famous algorithm
that makes the best use of this property that data
is sorted. And this algorithm is binary search.
So, can we make use of binary search in
this problem, one thing that we can do is
that using binary search, we can find out any
occurrence of the number x in the array. So,
let's say in this example, we want to find out
count of number five. So we let's say we find out
using binary search in big O of log n time, that
number five exists at index six. Now, because the
array is sorted, all occurrences of five will be
adjusting to this. So, we can go towards higher
indices starting this index, and look for all the
five and then we can go towards the lower indices,
and look for all occurrences of five. But once
again, if the whole array is number five, only,
all elements being same still is a sorted
array, then we will scan all the elements,
we will access all the elements in the array, and
eventually the time complexity will be big O of n,
only the time taken will be proportional to N
only in the worst case. So, using binary search
kind of does not give us much advantage if we
use binary search in its basic form, big O of
n because to perform binary search, we will take
big O of log n time. And then to find out all the
adjacent occurrences of x, we will take big O of
n in the worst case. So, for higher values of n,
log n is negligible in comparison to.
And so this is eventually big O of n,
we are not writing writing pseudocode for this
approach, we'll leave that as an exercise for
you. With these two approaches, we are still
big O of n in the worst case. So what do we do?
Well, if you remember from our previous
lessons on binary search, we can write a
binary search to find out the first occurrence
of an element in an array. And similarly,
we can write a variation of binary search to find
out the last occurrence of an element in an array.
And this forms the basis of our third approach.
And I'll clear some of this and make some space.
Okay, so we can use one variant of binary search
to find out the first occurrence of an element in
an array. And we can use another variation of
binary search to find out the last occurrence.
And if we know the last and the first
index at which the element occurs,
then we also know the count of it in the array.
So once again, we will write a method find count
that will take an array its size N and element
x. And let's say we find the first occurrence
of the element in the array using a method find
first, which is a variation of binary search.
And we will use another method called to another
variant of binary search, that will give us the
last occurrence of the element in the array, then
we can return count as last index minus first
index plus one. And I'm not handling the case
here when the element is not present in the array.
Let's say we will handle it well in our actual
implementation. Okay, so the first method call
if we are using binary search will work in big O
of log n and the second method call to find out
the last occurrence will also work in big O of
login. So overall, the time complexity to find out
the count of an element in the array would
be big O of log n. And that's really great.
We have described how to find out the first or
last occurrence of an element in a sorted array
using binary search. We had written pseudocode for
the algorithm in our previous lesson and there is
a link to the previous lesson in the description
of this lesson. But let us now go and write some
real code. To solve this problem. I will write a C
program. Let us first write a simple normal binary
search and then we will modify it to find the
first or the last occurrence. Let's say we have
a method binary search that gives me the index of
element x in the array. in binary search we first
define two indices low and high, two variables low
and high initially set to zero and n minus one,
respectively. And then we find the mid element
and as low plus the mid index as low plus high
upon two, and then we compare the middle
element with the number x. And if we,
if middle element is equal to x, we have found our
element. So we simply return the index mid else,
if x is less than the middle element because the
array is sorted, remember array being sorted is
a precondition of binary search, we set high
as mid minus one kind of saying that search
in the segment left to the middle element. And if
x is greater than the middle element, we adjust
lower to mid plus one. And we keep repeating
this process again and again till the time
we have a valid segment and a valid segment is
till the time low is less than or equal to high.
And if we come out of this loop without finding
anything, then we return minus one to say that
x does not exist in the array. problem with
this implementation is that as soon as we find
any x, we return. So there is no guarantee that
we will find the first index or the last index,
if there are duplicates in the duplicates of x
in the array. So what we do is we will, what we
will do is we will modify the algorithm slightly,
we will have another variable, initialize it to
minus one. And now when we find x, then we do not
return an exit, we update the result variable to
kind of say that, okay, this is the lowest index
of x so far, and then we continue the search.
So if we want to find out the first occurrence,
then we adjust high to mid minus one. So we
update result and go on searching towards lower
indices lower segment. And finally, if when we
come out of this loop, then we return result. So
if we do not find anything, any occurrence of x,
we simply return minus one, because this was
initialized to minus one. Now this implementation
will give us the first occurrence of x in the
array. And what if we wanted the last occurrence,
the only difference would be that we will go on
searching towards the right or higher indices,
so we will say that low is equal to eight plus one
now go on searching towards the higher indices.
Now I want two different functions for
finding out the first or the last occurrence.
But if you see there is difference in only
one line in these two implementations. So
what I'll do is I'll use the same function
to retrieve both first and the last index
based upon another argument of flag. So let's
say we have a flag as a Boolean parameter.
Search First, if it is true, we want to search
for the first occurrence and if it is false,
then we want to search for the last occurrence.
So if we want to search for the first occurrence,
then we want to, in the case, when a mid is equal
to x, we want to adjust high to mid minus one
else we want to adjust low to mid plus one.
Okay, let us know write the main method. What
I'll do is I'll first initialize an array.
And I'll ask the user to input a number
x. Now we want to find out the count of x.
So we will first make a call to binary search
method to find out the first index in the array.
So we will pass the array, the number of elements
in the array, which is 12. And we will also
calculate the number of elements using this
particular equation size of a upon size of
a zero size of the number of bytes in the
whole array upon the number of bytes in each
in teaser in each element. And we want to search
for x and we'll pass true because in our method
declaration, if this flag is passed as true, then
we search for the first index, else we search for
the last index. Now if first index is returned as
minus one, then the element is not in the array.
So no need to find the last index, we can
simply print that the count is zero. Else,
we find out the last index and this time we
make the call to the same function binary search
with only difference that this time we will pass
the flag as false. So we will say that, hey,
give me the last index. And we will print count
as last index minus first index plus one. So this
is our code. This is our method binary search.
And we have made call to binary search twice
to find out the first and the last index and we
decide first or last index using this flag. Let
us now run this code and see what happens. Let's
say we want to find out the count of number three,
then this gives us that three
occurs twice which is right.
Let's now try number five and count of five is
five. And let's give x is equal to two two is not
present in the array so the count will be zero.
So this is an optimized algorithm to find out
Count of an element in a sorted array. This
is a classic implementation of binary search.
In the coming lessons, we will see more problems
on binary search. So thanks for watching.
In this lesson, we will solve another
programming interview question.
And the question is that we are given a sorted
array that has been rotated. So let's say we have
been given a sorted array with these elements,
the size of the array is six, so we have indices
from zero to five. And let's say we want to
rotate this array anti clockwise rotate this
array towards the right. So, each element will
shift by one towards the right except the last
element which will shift to the first position in
the array and the resulting array would be this
and this is rotated once and if we rotate the
array twice, the resulting array would be this
and this is of course, rotated twice. And such
an array is often also called circularly sorted
array. So we have been given such a circularly
sorted array and there is one more condition there
are no duplicates in the array, all the elements
in the array are distinct. So given such an array,
we have to find out how many times the array has
been rotated. So how do we solve this problem?
One thing that should be pretty evident is that if
we know the first element or the minimum element
of the sorted sequence in the array, then we
know how many times the array has been rotated.
And when we say the number of times 30 has been
rotated, for this problem, we mean rotation in
anti clockwise direction or rotation towards the
right, the number of rotations of the array would
be the number of elements before the smallest
element or the minimum element in the array.
So in this case, there is only one element before
two which is the minimum. So clearly this array
is rotated once here we have two elements before
the minimum element. So this is rotated twice.
In fact, if we see then the number of rotations
is equal to the index of the minimum element.
So our problem is basically finding
out the minimum element in the array,
the index of the minimum element in the array.
And we are done. We know that how many times
the array has been rotated. So how do we
find out the index of the minimum element,
the simplest approach would be to scan the whole
array perform what we also call linear search.
And the pseudocode will be something like we
will have two variables, one to store the minimum
element and another to store the minimum index.
Let's say Initially, the first element is the
minimum element and then we run a loop from one
till n minus one where n is the size of the array.
And if the element at if index is less than the
minimum, we update the minimum and the minimum
index. And finally, when we come out of this loop,
we will have the index of the minimum element
Clearly, the running time of this algorithm
would be big O of n the running time will
be proportional to n. Now, this will give us the
correct answer, this is a correct solution. But in
this solution, we did not make use of the property
of the array that it is circularly sorted,
can we use this property of the array and improve
this algorithm improve the time complexity of this
algorithm? Well, let us see. Now, we will make use
of the property that array is circularly sorted,
and we will use a variation or modification of
binary search algorithm to solve this problem.
Now, what do we do in a normal binary search
algorithm? Let's say we have a sorted array like
this, we first find out the middle element in the
index in the array. And then we see whether this
is the element we are looking for or not. If
it is not the element that we are looking for,
we either go searching towards the left, or
we go searching towards the right based upon
whether the element that we're looking for is
greater than or less than the middle element.
So at each step, we divide the problem
into searching something in half the array.
at each step, we discard half of the elements,
we discard half of the search space, and we
keep on going until we find the element.
Now in a circularly sorted list like this,
our problem is to find out the first
element of the sorted sequence.
This particular element is kind of the pivot
or the junction in the circularly sorted array.
So now we will use a variation of binary search
to find out this pivot element which is also the
minimum element in the array. What we essentially
do in a binary search Is redefine a search space
or segment within which our desired element is
probable to live by two variables low and high,
the lower index and the higher index and at each
step, we either find an element or we reduce the
search space by half by discarding half of
the elements in the segment and creating a
new segment. And now, we look at the new
segment we kind of divide the problem
at each step into half. Now, in this problem for
each segment, we will look at couple of things,
there can be a case when the lower the element
at lower index is less than or equal to the
element at higher index. Now, this will be
possible only if the segment is already sorted,
if the segment is already sorted
the minimum element in the segment
and that's what we are finding out the minimum
element in the array and if we can find out
the minimum element in the segment that will
be the minimum element in the array as well.
So, we will return simply return the index
low because the array is already sorted. So,
the element at lower index is the minimum if the
segment is not sorted, we calculate the middle
index. And now, we try to see if our middle index
is the pivot or not. Now, how do we find out the
pivot if you see there is a special property of
the pivot or the minimum element in the array
if we see the next and the previous elements
of the pivot element in a circular manner. So,
if it is the last element, the next element will
be the first element, then for the pivot element
both next and previous element in the array are
greater than it like here 18 and five are both
greater than two. No other elements in the array
will have this property except the pivot element.
Let's define this property as pivot property.
So, here we calculate next as MIT plus one
modulo n modulo n because if mid is the
last index in the array, we need to go
to the first element. So, modular operation
does that and previous would be mid minus one
modulo n and we will also add n here so, that mid
minus one does not become a negative number. So,
our case too is that a made is less than or equal
to a next and it's also less than and equal to
less than or equal to the previous element in the
circular array in the circularly sorted array.
If this is the case, once again we have the
pivot or the minimum element in the array. So,
we will return the index made. So, far in these
two cases, we have found our element straight off
and we have not felt the need to divide
the array divide the search space segment.
If the middle element is not the pivot, then can
we use a property where we can say that we can
discard the right half or we can discard the left
half and we can go to one of the halves to search
for the pivot element. Well, yes, it is possible
to do so, if the middle element the element at
mid index is less than or equal to
the highest element at high index high
then the segment starting the mid index and
extending right towards till the high index,
this whole segment is sorted and the pivot cannot
exist in the right segment. So, in this case,
we will say that we need to search for the
pivot in the left half. So, we will adjust
high to mid minus one and case four would be
when the mid element is greater than or equal to
the element at lowest index. Now, in this case, it
is not possible that the pivot is in the left. So,
we will go and search in the right so,
we will adjust lower to mid plus one.
So, we keep reducing our segments at each
step and try to find out the answer. Now,
let us simulate this approach this algorithm for
this particular example. So, for this example,
case one obviously is not true initially. So,
we find out the middle index. Now, the pivot
property is not true for the middle index. So, we
look at case three, when we look at case three we
basically are looking whether this whole part of
the sequences sorted or not including 18 and the
whole elements towards the right. So, 18 is not
less than or equal to eight. Now, we look look for
case four. And when we look for case four, we
mean to check whether this complete sequence
is sorted or not. Well, this is sorted. In
fact, if the array is not sorted, then one
of these two sequences will always be sorted. You
can pick up some of examples, some examples and
try to see and this is what forms the basis
of our divide and conquer approach. This
is what forms the forms the basis upon
which we discard half of the elements.
So now we need to adjust low to mid plus one. So
we have discarded these elements from our search
space are not new search spaces starting at two.
Now this array is sorted. case one is true for
this segment, sorry, this segment is sorted. So
we simply return the index of two which is 0123,
and four, so, we return four here and our searches
over now, we have found the pivot element. So,
we know that the array is rotated four times
equal to the index of the pivot element
of things about this algorithm, this algorithm
will work only if there are no duplicates in
the array. And that was our initial condition
also in the problem, if there are duplicates
this reduction of search space into half is
not possible. And let us now write code for
this algorithm and see whether it works or not.
So, I will write a method find rotation count,
that will give me how many times a circularly
sorted array A is rotated, and is the number of
elements in the array. So, we first define low and
high. And then while our search space is valid, we
first see whether the segment is already sorted.
If it is sorted, we return the lower index.
So, this is our case one else we calculate mid as
low plus high upon two and then we also calculate
the next and previous have met. And if made
satisfies the pivot property we return made.
Else if the middle element is less than or equal
to the higher element, then we discard the right
half, and we adjust higher index to mid minus one
else, if a made is greater than or equal to a low,
then we discard the first half the left half.
If the array is not sorted, one of these two
conditions will always be true. And only one
of these conditions will be true, not the both
of them. Let's say if we are not able to return
anything, if we are not able to return anything
within the while loop, then we return minus one
it will be minus one will be returned only for
an invalid scenario when maybe the array is not
circularly sorted, its properties are not true.
Now, in the main method, I have
initialized an array of size 11.
And I have called this function find rotation
count. And I'm trying to print the count.
Let us see what happens if I run the program.
This says that the array is rotated six times,
which seems to be correct. Let's now modify
this array. Let's run this for a test case when
the elements are already sorted. Okay, this also
looks fine. So we are good. Now I have used four
cases to solve this problem. There are a couple of
different other implementation approaches as well,
the underlying idea would be the same to use
binary search. But we can implement using some
different conditions. I encourage you to try them
out on your own, or quickly Google search for
code snippets. So this was one interesting
problem using solve using binary search in
the coming lessons, we will see more such
interesting problems. Thanks for watching.
lesson we will solve yet another very famous
programming interview question. And the question
is that we are given a circularly sorted array,
which means that a sorted array has been rotated.
And in the previous lesson, we had also solved a
problem where we wanted to find out the number of
rotations in a circularly sorted array. This
is an example of a circularly sorted array,
the first element in the sorted
sequence is at index four,
and then we go towards the right. And then after
the last element, we go to the first element.
So this is the start of the sorted sequence.
And this is the end of the sorted sequence.
Each element in the sorted sequence has been
shifted four positions ahead, the array is
rotated four times in anti clockwise direction
or towards the right. Now given such an array,
we have to find out whether a number x exists
in this array or not. So how do we solve this
problem? The simplest approach would be to perform
a linear search, where we scan the whole array
to look for x. But in this approach, we will not
make use of the property of the array that it
is circularly sorted. And the time complexity for
this approach would be big O of n, where n is the
number of elements in the array. So what else
can we do? Whenever we have a sorted data,
and we have to search for something, we
should always think about binary search ads
as one of the possible approaches. Binary search
as we know executes in big O of n log n. At most,
we make log n comparisons to find out our element
in the array. And big O of log n is the best time
complexity to have for a solution. So let's see
if we can apply binary search in some form. To
solve this problem, let us pick up this circularly
sorted array, the example that we have in the left
and now we will use a variation of binary
search to find out an element x in the array
like we do in the normal binary search, we
will first define two indices low and high
initially to the first and the last element in the
array respectively. And then we find out the mid
element as low plus high upon to the mid index.
So far the logic is the same. Now, the first case
would be that the element at mid index a made is
equal to x. As we do in a normal binary search,
we will compare the middle element with the
number that we are looking for x and if this
is equal to x, our search is over we will return
made telling that x exists at index mid, if a mid
is not equal to x, then if the array was a normal
sorted array, then we would have either gone to
the left half or the right half depending upon
whether x is greater than or less than the middle
element. But we cannot apply this straightforward
logic to discard one of the half's in this case,
but there is a property that we can explore
it and discard half of the elements.
If you see then, the elements in
the array are always increasing
except only at this particular point, which
is the junction point or the pivot point,
where we have the first element or the
minimum element in the sorted sequence.
Now, if we pick any segment or any sub array,
then if it does not contain this pivot point,
if it does not contain these two
elements, which form the boundary,
the break point, then all the elements in this
segment will be sorted. And if the segment
contains these two elements that form the breaking
point, then the segment will not be sorted. Now,
the mid element divides the segment into two
halves and this breakpoint or the pivot point
will lie only in one of these halves. So, at
least one of these halves will always be sorted,
we will make use of this property and
we will discard half of the array at
half of the search space at each iteration of
the binary search. So, our case two will be
if a made is less than or equal to a high
basically we are looking at this particular
part of the array, we include the mid element
and look for the segment extending till the
highest element. If this condition is true, then
this whole segment is sorted. In this example,
this segment is not sorted. But if the segment
was sorted, the right segment was sorted,
then there would be two conditions let's
say these conditions are to a and to B,
we know that x is not equal to A made
but if x is greater than a made and
x is less than or equal to a high then
it definitely lies in this sorted half.
So, we adjust lower to mid plus one to say
that go ahead and search in the right half
as if it is not so, we will have a condition when
we will say go go search in the left half in the
unsorted half okay this will be the case when the
right half of the array sorted case three would be
when a low or the first element in the sequence
is less than or equal to the middle element less
than or equal to a mid. Now in this case, we are
looking whether this particular segment starting
low index all the way till mid index is sorted or
not. Now, once again we will have to condition to
conditions when we know that this half is sorted,
it is very easy to verify whether x is probable
to lie within this segment or not within this
sub segment or not here if x is greater than
or equal to a low and x is less than a made x
cannot be equal to the mid element because then we
will not reach the case three then x is probable
to lie in the left half for this condition.
So in this condition, we will adjust high to mid
minus one else we will search in the unsorted half
by adjusting low to mid plus one. So this is our
divide and conquer strategy for binary search.
Let us now write code for this And see if
it works, I will write a function circular
array search that will search for a number x in an
array of size n, and it will return the index of x
if it is found in the array. So like we do in a
normal binary search, we will first define two
variables low to zero and high to n minus one.
And while low is less than or equal to high,
while our search space is valid, while our segment
is valid, a valid segment segment will have at
least one element when low will be equal to high,
we calculate the mid index as low plus high upon
two. Now, if x is equal to the middle element,
then we have found x we return the index mid ELLs,
we need to decide whether to go in
the left half or the right half,
whether to go searching towards the higher indices
or the lower indices. And we do so by first
finding out which part of the array is which
part of the search space is sorted. If a made
is less than or equal to a high, the element
at index high, then the right half is sorted.
the right half is sorted, then we can easily
check whether x is probable to live within this
sorted half or not. So if x is greater than the
middle element, and x is less than or equal to
the element at index high, we go searching
to the right sorted half by adjusting
low to mid plus one. Else, we know that the
element is not in the right half, so it is
definitely in the left half. So we will adjust
high to mid minus one to go to the left half.
Now, right half is sorted for sure we know
that but left half, it could either be sorted
or unsorted, it doesn't matter. For some special
case, when the segment itself is sorted, the left
half could also be sorted. But irrespective
of that, using these two conditions, we are
discarding one of the halves and we are going to
one of the we're choosing one of the sub segments.
Okay, so now if the right half is not sorted,
then the left half definitely will be sorted.
So either we write this condition A
made greater than or equal to a low.
Or maybe I should write a low less than or equal
to emit as we had written previously. So this is
case three, even if we do not write this condition
and simply write an else we are fine because
this will be true anyway, at this point. So now
the left half is sorted. So we can see whether
our x is probable to lie in left half. Now if if
x is between a low and a mid less than or equal to
greater than or equal to a low and less than
a mid, then it's probable to lie in this half.
So we will adjust high to mid minus one. Else
if x is not probable to lie in the left half,
then we go searching towards the right
by adjusting low to mid plus one.
And finally, if we come out of this while loop
without finding x, without returning anything,
we return minus one to say that we could not find
x in the array. Let us now write the main method,
we will first initialize an array and this is the
same array. The elements are the same as we have
used in our examples throughout. Now let's ask
the user to input a number x from the console.
And now we call the method to search for x, the
size of the array is eight. So we pass eight as
the second argument. Now if this method returns
minus one, we will say that we could not find the
element in the array, the number in the array.
And if it is not minus one, we print the index.
So this is our C program. And now
let's run this and see what happens.
Let's search for the number eight in the array.
And this seems to be correct. The element eight is
at index six. Let's run this again and search for
number 12 in the array. And this also is correct.
And this seems to be working
for other cases as well.
And let's modify this array. Let's say we want to
pick up an array in which the elements are already
sorted. Let's pick up eight elements again.
Let's search for element four in this array,
okay, this is also fine. So we
seem to be good for all test cases.
Well actually no we are not good for all test
cases. If we have an array with duplicates,
like this, this array is still circularly sorted.
This is the first element in the sorted sequence
zero. But if we have duplicates in the circularly
sorted array, it will not be possible to
decide whether left half is sorted or right half
is sorted. Using the conditions above that we have
used using these this condition. So the array has
to be strictly increasing in a circular manner,
and all the elements need to be distinct. If we
run this, let's say we want to search for a number
zero, then this is zero not found in the array
which is not correct. If there are duplicates,
we cannot do any better than big O of n, we
will have to perform linear search only if
the elements are distinct, we can perform binary
search. Okay, so this was searching an element
in a circularly sorted array with no duplicates
using binary search. Thanks for watching.